[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es eine
schritt-für-schritt-anleitung für den
perfekten türkischen reis und es gibt
immer die eine variante vom türkischen
reis das ist die die wir nicht so mögen
das ist dieses klebrige dieser weiße
reist das mögen wir nicht so es gibt
aber auch die andere variante das ist
wirklich diese traditionelle reist wo
dann auch noch die nudeln mit rein
kommen was dann wirklich mit
langkornreis gemacht wird und total
feind ist und wo wirklich jedes reiskorn
zu sehen ist also einfach nur locker und
leicht genau und dafür haben wir jetzt
auch wirklich nur fünf zutaten die
fünfte ist auch eine optional also ich
habe hier was manche langkornreis dann
habe ich hier diese speziellen nudeln
das sind die sharia nudeln natürlich
salz etwas sonnenblumenöl und die zwei
das optional das ist ganz normale mutter
und dass wir natürlich auch noch
benötigen ist kochendes wasser und hier
ist auch immer ganz wichtig ihr habt
gerade gesehen ich habe ein glas voller
reis deshalb nämlich einer teil leser
voller wasser das ist mal ganz wichtig
weil viele nebenbei bestimmten
reissorten dann ein glas reis und zwei
gläser wasser bei dem langkornreis ich
hier mal für den türkischen ressort
wende immer nur eineinhalb gläser wasser
damit eben nicht zu matschig wird so der
allererste schritt und das ist auch
einer der wichtigsten ist dass wir den
reis einmal auswaschen dann hätte
einfach lauwarmes oder kaltes wasser und
dann seht ihr schon dass die das der
eisstärke enthält und die stärke bewegt
einfach dass es dann wenn ihr es nicht
rausfällt total pampig und matschig wird
und es wollen wären nicht das heißt
haltet neuer glas unten drunter und ihr
seht das wasser ist trüb und wenn ihr
das dann lang genug aus warst also
ungefähr 34 minuten dann ist das wasser
was unten rauskommt komplett klar und
die ganze stärke aus und wenn das
erledigt ist können wir über an den herd
und mit dem topf einmal anfangen im topf
wird jetzt zuallererst öl erhitzt da
könnt ihr auch feucht beispiel stufe 6
von neuen nehmen und da gibt ihr die
nudeln rhein und die werden dann schön
braun angebraten
[Musik]
jetzt sind die nudeln hellbraun das hat
jetzt ungefähr eineinhalb bis zwei
minuten gedauert an der stelle einmal
den gewaschenen reis dazugeben und für
circa eine halbe minute mitbraten
[Musik]
sobald ihr den reis dazu gibt ganz
wichtig geht mit der stufe gerne runter
auf 3 oder schon noch zwei damit es eben
nicht auf dem boden an pub und ihr müsst
jetzt auch ständig umrühren das ist ganz
ganz wichtig und da reißt entwickelt
auch rest aromen also ihr richtern so
lustigen geruch also merkt es richtig
und an der stelle das gekochte wasser
dazugeben
wie gesagt die einen teig leser jetzt in
meinem fall und dann kommt auch schon
das salz dazu und der reis wird gegart
ganz ganz wichtig den deckel einmal
schließen und dann dauert das so
ungefähr 18 bis 20 minuten ich nehme
immer stufe 2 von 9
[Musik]
der reis ist fertig und man sich jetzt
schon dass der total fein ist weil die
reis spitzen so nach oben gucken und
deswegen habe ich auch am anfang gesagt
dass die zutat butter optional ist für
mich ist er so schon perfekt und er
schmeckt auch sehr gut aber wenn ihr das
so ein bisschen betrüger möchte der ist
ja butter ist geschmacksträger dann tut
er gerne noch ein bisschen butter rein
nachdem das ganze fertig gegart ist ich
nehme dafür jetzt ganz einfach immer
teelöffel weise ein bisschen butter und
nimmt dann um das ganze aufzulockern
einfach zwei gaben
[Musik]
richtig könig ja das ist der perfekte
türkische reiste ist einfach nur perfekt
so ihr lieben ich lass euch jetzt den
reis selber nach kochen zu hause ich
entlasse euch also viel freude beim
nachmachen schaut hier unten in die
video beschreibungen ihr die ganz
genauen mengenangaben sehen möchtet und
dann könnt ihr mir auch gerne in die
kommentare schreiben welches basic das
habt ihr als nächstes sehen möchte
unsere idee war der arabische reis dass
ich euch denen gerne mal zeige nach der
abmahner china war das ist nämlich auch
echt lecker ich kenne ich besser finde
ich es nicht wenn beide mega gut okay
ich sage jetzt nichts weiter und ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel freude und
nachkochen last im video gerne ein
bisschen nach oben wenn euch das rezept
gefällt und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten wie die euch hier auf meinem
kanal zschau
[Musik]